[Musique]
la responsabilité de tout gouvernement
canadien c'est d'assurer le bien-être la
protection la sécurité mais aussi la
prospérité des Canadiens
en même temps qu'on fait ça on doit
évidemment être là pour se tenir debout
pour nos valeurs et nos principes et
s'attendre à ce que nos règles et nos
lois soient suivies
juste un traîneau à Londres un peu plus
tôt ce matin sur l'expulsion éventuelle
du diplôme chinois impliqué dans les
menaces à l'endroit du député Michael
Chang et de sa famille ce sont les plus
récentes révélations dans le dossier de
la gérance étrangère qui ont dominé le
débat ici toute la semaine dernière et
qui ont dominé le point de près du
Premier ministre qui était à Londres
pour le couronnement du roi Charles que
doit faire le gouvernement maintenant
voyons voir ce qu'on pense mes
collaborateurs avec kastanguay est
animateur de midi info et si première
Chantal Hébert et chroniqueur au Toronto
Star et au magazines l'actualité et
Michel CEG est analyste politique la
Radio-Canada et la presse bon dimanche à
vous trois
diplôme on y réfléchit nous dit-on mais
ce qu'on a vraiment le choix est-ce
qu'on peut ne pas expulser ce diplomate
là
je pense qu'on va se résoudre à expulser
ce diplomate quand on a une controverse
de cet ampleur un rapport du SARS ça
c'est clair sur les pressions qui ont
été faites par cette consult Toronto
auprès de la famille de Michael Chang
rester à Hong Kong il faut agir je pense
que ce serait envoyé un très mauvais
message à la Chine mais aux autres pays
que de ne pas agir assez fermement et de
l'expulser le problème c'est que c'est
la Chine et nos relations étant déjà
tendues la Chine a déjà lancé le message
très clair qu'ils allaient répliquer le
communiqué de l'ambassadeur chinois
Ottawa était assez clair pour eux c'est
des folies c'est de la désinformation
c'est n'importe quoi et il y aura des
représailles si leur consul à Toronto
est expulsé maintenant je pense que on
essaie de vérifier Ottawa de quel
ampleur seront ces représailles ce qu'on
expulse un diplomate canadien
représailles sont on peut vivre avec ça
est-ce qu'on en exclut 5 6 7 est-ce
qu'on va prendre en otage un autre
citoyen canadien en Chine vous avez il y
a beaucoup de beaucoup d'incertitudes
autour de la réplique de la Chine est-ce
qu'on va fermer les importations de
produits canadien le soya le port ou je
sais pas quoi alors c'est ça qu'on est
en train d'essayer de juger mais
éventuellement je pense qu'on devra pour
le message que ça envoie au Canadien et
aux puissances étrangères se résoudre à
expulsé ce diplomates chinois ok Michel
les chanteurs
il faut simplement chinois qui refait
des choses qui sont incompatibles avec
ses fonctions c'est-à-dire de
congélateur
cela dit maintenant on sait que quand on
parle à la Chine on a on applique plus
le livre de règlement diplomatique les
règles ne sont plus les mêmes autrefois
c'était bon en expulsion j'en expulsion
pendant on oublie ça là ça peut être
complètement autre chose ça peut être
effectivement un embargo sur des
produits canadiens ça peut être facile
fermée votre consulat à Shanghai
ou encore on en explose plusieurs puis
on aura l'ambassade du Canada
beaucoup moins performante parce que ces
gens-là qui travaillent et on a besoin
d'un certain nombre de kilomètres dans
un pays comme la Chine alors c'est vrai
depuis les deux Michael il y a plus rien
de pareil alors je sais pas comment ils
vont jouer justement mais c'est une
décision difficile à prendre je suis
d'accord j'attends
ce qu'on voit c'est des pressions
politiques intenses sur le gouvernement
Trudeau pour qu'on expulse un diplôme ce
qu'on voit pas c'est dépressions selon
moi au moins aussi intense sur le
gouvernement Trudeau en provenance d'une
foule de milieu d'affaires producteur
canalope la liste pour qu'on en veut
même pas les relations avec la Chine et
qu'on n'ouvre pas la porte à une
escalade
entre les deux gouvernements et ces
pressions là il y a pas seulement le
gouvernement Trudeau qui les ressent en
passant il y a aussi le Parti
conservateur de Pierre poillie chaque
journée amène son lot de nouvelles
pressions sur les deux principaux partis
et vous l'entendez ça dans la
déclaration qu'on a fait jouer de Justin
Trudeau le mot opérant ces prospérités
c'est pas un accident que le mot
prospérité soit dans la déclaration du
Premier ministre et selon moi c'est pas
un accident qui comprennent le temps
aussi de réfléchir en se disant il y a
des gens qui disent qu'on allait faire
mais pendant ce temps-là la pression
monte aussi sur pierre poillière les
milieux d'affaires au Canada les milieux
qui produisent et qui sont engagés en
Chine veulent pas avoir un cowboy comme
premier ministre alors j'ai hâte de voir
ce qu'on va faire mais je vous ferai
aussi valoir que si j'étais un service
de sécurité canadien peut-être que
j'aimerais mieux la taupe que je connais
et que je suis que l'atome suivante que
je vais devoir identifier
vu comme ça on garde nos ennemis plus
près Michel est-ce que ce qu'on a appris
cette semaine ça c'est un élément de
plus dans tout le dossier de la gérance
chinoise on en parle à toutes les
semaines mais à chaque semaine il y a un
élément supplémentaire qui vient
s'ajouter ça là c'est ça
est-ce que c'est un élément déterminant
parce que ça cible un député élu quand
même ça fait beaucoup de vagues cette
semaine
c'est du nom c'est plus haut comme comme
menace là on est dans un député élu
l'ancien ministre
candidats
alors oui ça fait ça fait monter les
enchères et je pense que plusieurs
semaines on est trois ça
rend l'enquête publique de plus en plus
inévitable mais là c'est je pense que
c'est le dernier cloud dans cette
histoire là c'est intéressant s'inquiète
du fait que le premier ministre a dit
cette semaine mais je le savais pas je
l'ai appris dans le journal c'est pas le
genre de projet d'information qui aurait
dû se rendre au Premier ministre
probablement mais
on peut croire juste un Trudeau et en
même temps constater qu'il y a eu un
concours de circonstance c'est-à-dire on
est à l'été 2021
le conseiller à la sécurité nationale de
Monsieur Trudeau prend sa retraite ou
kit de son poste on assure l'intérim
donc c'est pas déjà dit la personne qui
est là actuellement et pendant l'intérêt
mais on assure l'intérim de l'intérim
pour le temps des vacances
en même temps le gouvernement est en
train de déclencher une campagne
électorale alors en mettant tous ces
éléments là ensemble on se dit les
conditions parfaites sont réunies pour
que quelque chose tombe entre deux
bureaux et il ramasse la poussière et
c'est à peu près la seule version qui
explique que ça soit pas rendu plus haut
cela dit c'est sûr que ça donne une
drôle d'impression un des services de
sécurité qui reviennent pas pour dire
que ce qui est arrivé à notre rapport
deux de la conseillère à la sécurité
nationale qui découvre ce morceau de
papier en deux bureaux à ce moment-ci
évidemment le Premier ministre qui a
l'air de diriger un gouvernement qui qui
est un peu brouillon un peu beaucoup
ce qui se passe autour de lui
non ce sont mais les circonstances sont
effectivement assez particulières mais
il y a eu un problème dans la chaîne de
commandement dans le protocole du SRS
poudre reviser ça d'ailleurs on croit
comprendre qu'à partir de maintenant dès
que se touchera un élu peu importe le
parti politique on préviendra le Premier
ministre en fonction qui lui préviendra
ensuite le député pour qui est qui soit
au courant de ce qui se passe concernant
lui ou sa famille donc on va ajuster ce
protocole là qui était clairement
déficient parce que c'est vrai que même
si c'était les vacances de tout le monde
en deux gouvernements le protocole
aurait dû être un peu plus clair que ça
peut-être aussi qu'il faudrait que le
CRS soit plus clair dans ses rapports je
sais pas comment celui-ci est rédigé moi
je ne l'ai pas constaté je ne l'ai pas
lu contrairement globet de mer mais
parfois le CRS ou la GRC écrivent des
rapports où on est assez flou juste
assez flou pour dire quelque chose qui
se passe mais pas très précis pour être
capable de faire quoi que ce soit avec
on a déjà vu ça dans le passé sa place
le politicien ou la personne en
responsable la sécurité nationale dans
un dilemme en disant mais vous me dites
pas la marche à suivre vous me dites pas
s'il faut que je fasse quelque chose
vous faites juste me dire il y a un peu
de fumée qu'est-ce que je fais avec
cette fumée là peut-être que le sars
aussi va avoir à réviser la manière dont
on rédige les rapports lorsqu'il est
question d'élus et que ce donc c'est
quand même les dans le cas des élus le
cœur la démocratie canadienne
effectivement bon là je vous épargne la
suite des choses parce que ça fait trois
semaines qu'on dit ça commence à devenir
de plus en plus difficile d'éviter
l'enquête publique on va reparler
probablement d'ici la fin du mois de mai
avant de partir pour Londres monsieur
Trudeau il était à son congrès de son
parti on va en écouter un extrait parce
que il y a un discours très très oui
passé à l'attaque contre Pierre poilliev
on va en écouter un extrait on vient
là-dessus
[Musique]
question
aways of money walk
tu es où
time for you to wake up
c'est beau du discours que probablement
plus grosse réaction dans la salle
Chantal le monsieur Trudeau a-t-il
réussi à énergiser ses militants parce
qu'on se disait il faut qu'il les bras
c'est un peu pour qu'il leur donne
l'impression que les choses vont bien ça
a fonctionné
pendant 20 25 ans vous moi Michel Alex
on s'est promené dans des couloirs de
congrès libéraux ou tout ce dont on
parlait dans le couloir parce que c'est
des ça a toujours été la tendance
libérale de faire des gros happenings of
you on a vu le nombre de délégués et
faméliques qui se présente pour avoir
des vrais débats et qui parle sur la
plupart des débats d'ailleurs c'est pas
Charles d'événement mais on se promène
un couloir et on nous disait on serait
peut-être mieux avec Paul Martin ou si
vous remontez plus loin c'est peut-être
mieux avec Jean-Chrétien
c'est pas ce genre de congrégat auquel
on a assisté en fin de semaine les gens
qui étaient là tout au moins semblent
résolu qu'on entend résigner faites la
gamme mais néanmoins à faire la
prochaine campagne électorale avec
ceinture d'eau comme chef
trop difficile d'arriver à cette
conclusion là parce que la vérité c'est
qu'il y en a pas parmi les candidats
dont on parle il y en a pas de candidat
possible dont on peut dire qu'il ferait
franchement vraiment mieux que je suis
un Trudeau en campagne électorale
Michel est-ce que ce que les délégués
ont discuté comme proposition cette fin
de semaine sa place le parti dans une
dans une position combative contre
Monsieur foyer un programme des
résolutions très à gauche on a eu
l'impression que ça où est-ce que ça les
place
le gouvernement est très à gauche depuis
un bout de temps plus à gauche que la
position normale du Parti libéral du
Canada disons alors il y a deux choses
là-dedans oui ça c'est des c'est tous
des résolutions qui disent on va faire
plus pour des Canadiens en même temps il
y a des Canadiens qui vont poser des
questions et il y a des libéraux qui ont
posé la question cette fin de semaine à
un moment donné ce qu'on ce que l'argent
pose dans les arbres est-ce qu'on peut
continuer à faire comme pendant la
pandémie là quand on a partout puis
qu'on alors ça ça c'est une question
réelle une question réelle que Monsieur
poignet peut poser sans être sans dans
les les cultures etc là où il semble se
complaire actuellement
le danger pour avec le discours de
Monsieur Trudeau qu'on a vu en fin de
semaine c'est que l'argumentaire du
Parti libéral soit vous ne voulez pas
bien poignet comme premier ministre et
qui est pas de programme libéral
présenté ou qu'il ne paraissent pas par
rapport à on veut pas bien ça ce serait
un danger pour le parti libéral ils ont
quand même encore le temps de devoir
venir de régler ça là est-ce que
Monsieur Trudeau peut faire campagne en
disant je il vous faut protéger ce que
l'on a acquis au cours des 8 dernières
années
non je pense à prendre toujours des
nouvelles politiques pour être capable
de montrer qu'on est capable de se
renouveler d'avoir des nouvelles idées
mais moi je trouve que le plus
significatif cette semaine en termes de
dynamique de politique canadienne c'est
passé à l'extérieur du congrès libéral
parce que le bout de discours de Justin
Trudeau que vous avez pas présenté qui
suit après c'est inimaginaire pourquoi
il pense que Pierre polieb ne s'est pas
réveillé qui est pas qui est pas
réveillé puis il y a les changements
climatiques dedans et c'est une semaine
où on a eu les inondations ma foi assez
catastrophique dans Charlevoix dans
Gatineau à Laval dans les régions de
Montréal l'Alberta et littéralement en
feu actuellement on est rendu à plus de
25000 personnes évacuées de leurs
résidence parce qu'on est à des
centaines de feux de forêt dont
plusieurs dizaines sont incontrôlés
actuellement pleine campagne électorale
alors si on a des rappels qu'on a des
gros problèmes de changement climatique
et d'adaptation changement climatique
cette semaine c'est une bonne semaine
pour ça et on est toujours très
vulnérable chez les conservateurs par
rapport à ce sujet là on veut constru
exploiter du pétrole on veut pas mettre
d'argent dans l'adaptation changement
climatique on veut grosso modo mettre à
terre la taxe sur le carbone qui est un
acquis donc juste intrudo va
certainement parler en campagne
électorale donc un moment donné là il y
a aussi cette oui elle est discours des
politiciens oui à la façon dont on va
essayer de présenter de cadrer la
campagne électorale le meilleur la
réalité des gens qui sont au prises avec
des pompiers volontaires qui meurent
puis les sous-sol qui sont inondés puis
les feux de forêt qui font des ravages
dans des municipalités de l'Alberta sans
compter la Colombie Britannique dans les
dernières années puis c'est ce qui s'est
passé à Fiona dans les provinces
atlantiques je trouve que ça a été une
mauvaise semaine pour les conservateurs
pas raison de ce que Justin Trudeau a
dit mais parce que la réalité va un
moment donné les rattraper j'entends
c'est le débat du siècle les
conservateurs veulent faire comme si ça
existait pas et moi je crois pas
effectivement que la police peut
survivre une campagne électorale ou
mener un gouvernement minoritaire à la
Chambre des communes en disant que la
question des changements climatiques
c'est une question pour les works
quelques secondes sur les changements
climatiques
c'est quelque chose qui va toucher tout
le monde et qui va qui est en train de
revoir même les relations par exemple au
Québec on le voit entre les
municipalités et le gouvernement
professionnel cette belle attention aux
villes puis ils vont parler au
gouvernement fédéral aussi il y a papa
qui sont les premières touchées et qui
là sentent qu'ils ont besoin d'aide ça
va clairement revenir d'ailleurs on en
parlait avec le nouveau président de
l'UMP un peu plutôt à l'émission on va
en parler des changements climatiques
avec Chantal Michel merci beaucoup bonne
fin de weekend